if you're gonna go hang out and do stuff
undercover you know it's it's it's yeah
the murder story where you interview the
six characters and you put it together
dramatic video I mean you got to go get
it yeah there's no guarantee and as much
as you try to get it set up and you
weren't you know side by side with law
enforcement so you know something could
happen that'll that'll constitute
interesting television there's no
guarantee I mean there's nothing worse
than going out talking your executive
producers into doing something spending
the money yeah and then missing the guy
at the last minute I mean we're going
after a guy it's a horrible case where
this guy was raping his eleven-year-old
stepdaughter and did it for like four
years and we did the story and and they
had let him out on parole yeah how they
got these nonviolent drug offenders who
have been in for 29 years they want to
get this guy out after you know farlis
right and so we're gonna go chase him
down he's working at this plant you know
I was gonna I was false it to confront
him I driven around it we'd checked it
out
and we're there and I just you know I
jumped the gun too early he saw and his
buddy smuggled him out a back gate
across you know and I got a call Los
Angeles and say hey Oh how'd it go was
it really good was a traumatic well it
was 20,000 down the drain today yeah
yeah there's something you know yeah
yeah it's not a good conversation right
do you feel yeah at a certain point does
it get tricky though and like you know
there's an executive there's a there's a
financial push to like get it right and
it's like you have to like did you ever
feel like at that point your bet you're
you're sacrificing integrity no nobody's
ever asked me to sacrifice integrity oh
wow and again that you know I started
television 1981 Wow when I was still in
college and making $4 in 80 cents an
hour 39 hours a week and then what
full-time when I when I graduated but
honestly and I know these questions come
up with different syndicates that own
different groups of television stations
and you know are you pro this or pro
that or your right wing left wing but
I've never felt it ever yeah and you
know in a lot of years and yeah I mean
are there realistic constraints in terms
of budget absolutely you know do we
Nessus
ciara LIGO around the world that we once
did you gotta justify it right and you
got to make sure the audience is there
yeah it's different shows used to go
around the world a lot more and now
everything it's I mean budgets are
smaller and bigger pieces production
companies take bigger pio you know
overall there's back people behind the
scene who's your audience right and do
you spend a year going undercover and
going to India to expose human drug
trials of something that you know is
dangerous but you caught them doing I
mean it's good TV it's a variety V you
win and over seas Press Club award maybe
an Emmy but you know where do you put
your resources right and that's the you
know depending on the show you know look
crime is big look alive crime is big
I've literally got four shows in the
work smile all crime and I love crime
it's it's it's it's it's in its
importance what I've always done I mean
I just didn't start doing this you know
four years ago because it was popular
you know do you think it would be more
exciting to die of natural causes or -
honestly to get murdered be honest I
just want a long life I really but at
the end though I took everyone a long
life okay but when you get to the end of
that long life I think about this but I
want to die of natural causes or is
there something exciting about getting
murdered I don't want to get murdered I
can accept a horrible ski accident I can
accept a heart attack doing something
that I truly was passionate about right
but I don't need to you know have a
cleanup crew I just think it would be
that land I just watched the equalizer -
on the plane or the audience I that does
seem more blood and guts today than
normal good afternoon and other times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one